the media and politicians break out the
coveted panic but do the statistics
justify it
plus joe biden is unwilling to accept
the consequences of his own economic
agenda i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
show is sponsored by expressvpn i
protect my data with a vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
alrighty we'll get to all the news in
just one second first
you may have noticed that your cell
phone bill is just too high it is just
too high why have you not switched over
to pure talk usa yet i mean it's super
simple
it's got the same great coverage because
pure talk is on the exact same network
as one of the big three but at a
fraction of the price and switching
is as easy as switching out your sim
card you can keep your phone keep your
number or get huge discounts on the
latest iphones and androids when you
join puretalk usa plus right now here's
what you get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and here's the
thing you're saying to yourself what if
i use like eight gigs of data
if you go over on the data they're not
going to charge you for it there's a
reason pure talk is the highest rated
wireless company
by consumer affairs and why they are the
preferred wireless partner
of amac a lot of phone companies will
sort of confuse you intentionally on
what exactly you are getting when you
sign up for their cell phone service
not so with the transparency that you
will receive with pure talk
usa from your cell phone so i'll pound
250 say ben shapiro save an additional
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero say my name
ben shapiro to get started again dial
pound two five zero
say ben shapiro save an additional fifty
percent off your very first month
of pure talk usa go check them out right
now
alrighty so panic has broken out across
the land with regard to the delta
variant it's
resulting in some pretty dumb policy and
here is the thing
in order to understand what is going on
with covet you actually have to look at
the chart
because what's actually happening right
now is that you're seeing an increased
number of cases
the people who are getting very ill and
dying of covet right now
are almost universally unvaccinated the
people who are getting
the disease after having been vaccinated
are typically getting
very mild forms of it they're getting
either asymptomatic
or very very mild symptomatic forms and
anybody who's being hospitalized
after having had the covid vaccine and
then getting covered these tend to be
older people with significant
underlying vulnerabilities and yet if
you look at the way that the media cover
this stuff it's it's totally wild i mean
they're not giving you
the real story they'll tell you things
like the increase
in in covet deaths it's up 25 that's
something that you saw
from usa today you're seeing that
there's an increase in deaths
it's 25 up okay well that relies on the
baseline
what exactly is the baseline number of
deaths okay that's really what we should
be looking at
instead of looking at you know we are
higher than we were two weeks ago in
terms of death it should be okay what is
the baseline level of death so
in order to understand how bad things
actually are
you have to have a little bit of
perspective okay when things were at
their worst in terms of the number of
deaths
in the united states we were looking at
sometimes 4 000 deaths a day
sometimes just under 4 000 deaths a day
you can see
that sort of peak on this chart right
there right when you see that it reaches
its height you're looking at again
sometimes 5 000 deaths a day those are
huge numbers
huge numbers here are the causes the top
causes of death
in the united states deaths day by day
in the united states now again
these causes of death are average across
all of the days so some days are higher
and some days are lower this is just the
average
okay in the united states every year
there are millions of deaths every
single year in the united states because
we're a very large country of 330
million citizens
so here are the number of deaths per day
by cause in the united states
heart disease is 2019 heart disease
about 1806 deaths per day from heart
disease in the united states
from cancer they're about 1 643 deaths
per day
again as of 2019. accidents right like
car accident fall off your balcony get
hit by an anvil that's 474 deaths per
day
chronic lower respiratory diseases
that'd be like 430 deaths a day
stroke is 410 deaths per day alzheimer's
is 332 deaths per day and diabetes is
240 deaths per day
so why exactly am i bringing that up
because how many deaths per day are we
having in the united states right now
if you just looked at the media coverage
you would think that we were up near the
top of that chart right
just like we were when we were at the
worst of this thing when we were
averaging
you know we had two week running
averages of three thousand four thousand
deaths per day
you know doubling the highest the the
highest rate of death from another
disease
in the united states as of 2019. now you
would think that we were up in the
stratosphere somewhere around like heart
disease or cancer
no the seven day rolling average as of
right now the seven day rolling average
in terms of deaths in the united states
is under 300 which puts us in about the
realm of alzheimer's or diabetes
and not even of heart it's like six
times lower than the rate of death
on a daily average for heart disease
across the entire year okay and right
now we are talking about a seven-day
rolling average not across
the entire year and what does this
suggest it suggests
that while we are seeing an increased
number of infections the number of
deaths are not skyrocketing
and this is not a coincidence in the
united states i'm looking at the uk's
chart right now because the uk
started seeing the delta variant before
the united states did now
back in january the uk sort of hit its
height
in terms of the number of cases that
were being diagnosed in the uk day on
day
okay back in january 8th for example had
about 68 000 new cases that had been
diagnosed
now they're having about 45
50 000 new cases diagnosed every day
right so there are some pretty high
numbers there in the uk in terms of
diagnosis
the difference is that if you look at
the death levels radically different
back in january the uk was experiencing
about 600 deaths per day
today the uk is experiencing about 40.
like 10 times lower more than 10 times
lower
why because as it turns out the number
of people
who are getting this thing or vaccinated
are not being hospitalized and not dying
generally speaking
and the same thing holds true if you
look at the statistics from israel
right now what you're seeing there's a
lot of misinformation that is
circulating right now
about the fact that there are some
breakthroughs of the delta variant
against the coveted vaccine
again breakthrough as far as being
diagnosed with it
but not a breakthrough as far as dying
from it and this is the thing i care
about i don't care if i get the flu as
long as i don't die and i don't get
seriously oh from it
why do i possibly care about that the
only thing that makes a difference
especially in terms of government action
is level of death if you're just talking
about a bunch of people got diagnosed
with the flu this year and very few
people died no one cares we don't shut
down businesses for that we certainly
don't mask up for that
okay so in israel right which has been
sort of the big headline
wow look at israel so highly vaccinated
and yet and yet and now israel
because politicians always have a stake
in control
they do our health apparatus has a stake
in control they don't want to give it up
and i think what the last year proved is
that americans are willing to give up
their liberty for pretty much
anything it is one thing for people to
give up their liberty when there is a
serious risk
to them but for people to willingly give
up their liberty
while they are already vaccinated
against a disease is pretty messed up
and to give up your child's liberty
based on pretty much nothing is even
more messed up as we'll get to so what
is the story in israel where there are
all these headlines about how we need to
shut down again
israel has now closed travel to
foreigners again through august 1st
so what exactly is happening in israel
well here's what's happening
right now the the vaccines mostly fires
are in israel
are 90 plus effective against severe
disease
for people who are under the age of 65
in israel
90 plus effectiveness which means we
have now lowered the rates of death
down below the flu for people who are
under the age of 65. it is 80 percent
plus effective against severe disease
for people over the age of 65. so israel
right now is looking at booster shots
one of the reasons that they're looking
at booster shots is because older people
have immunity that tends to wane faster
but the covet variant
is still not effective against pfizer in
the sense of killing or hospitalizing
tons and tons of people
it just isn't and the reason that you're
seeing some stats
that are out there again people need to
understand base rates the reason you're
seeing some stats that are out there
like for example in israel 40 percent of
all people who are being hospitalized
for covet or people who've already
had the vaccine that's because like 75
percent of israel's population has
already had the vaccine
i mean theoretically if it were supposed
to be equal then 75
of people who are being hospitalized
would have had the vaccine but that's
not what you're seeing
what you're saying is that it is
preventative of getting the disease and
it is super
preventative of getting seriously ill
and dying
and as it turns out that and the the
other thing to recall here is that when
we are talking about the relative safety
of populations again one of the reasons
that you are seeing a lower level of
death
even though you're seeing a spike in
cases in both the united states and the
uk
as well as israel is that one of the
things that has happened
here is that the people who are getting
covet are much younger
the people who are getting covered right
now are much younger if you look in the
united states for example at the
vaccination rates by age and right now
i'm looking at the
statistics from the cdc right now
there are 85.42 of people
who are age 65 to 74 in the united
states
have had at least one dose of the
vaccine
in fact if you are 75 and older
83 of that population has received at
least one dose of the vaccine
you have like 76 of all people
over the age of 65 essentially 75 76
of that entire population is completely
vaccinated why
because people rationally risk assess if
you're 65 plus
you're much more scared of covey and you
ought to be much more scared of cover
than if you are 20.
and so the people who are the most
vulnerable already backed up and those
people
are tending to get less six sick they're
tending to die less they're tending to
get the disease less
and so while you're seeing a spike in
cases among people who are younger and
healthier
they're also not dying at the same rates
as people who are 80. because this
disease think
you know thank god because only thank
god in the sense that it would have been
much much worse if it had targeted
children
but it doesn't really affect people who
are younger nearly as much as it affects
people who are older
right now in the united states about 50
percent of the population somewhere in
that neighborhood
is actually baxed in the united states
but it really matters what age you are
talking about
because if you're under the age of 12
for example apparently about 31
of people who are aged 12 to 15 have
received a dose of the vaccine
but i'm not sure like why that's high
priority
to avoid infecting people who are 65 who
already should have had the vaccine
so here is the point everybody is
treating this stuff as a crisis
it is not in fact a crisis we are not at
crisis levels right now
we're not and it's and also we're not at
crisis when everybody had the
opportunity to get the vaccine
you see how the goal posts have shifted
in terms of what the goals are of public
policy here
at the beginning the lockdowns and the
masking recommendations
they were all designed in order to
prevent overwhelming of the hospital
system has anybody said anything
remotely like that recently
that the hospital systems are on the
verge of being overwhelmed you're not
hearing it
the reason you're not hearing it is
because it's not happening if the
hospitals in the united states are not
even close to on the verge of being
overwhelmed
this is also true in the uk it's also
true in israel none of the hospitals in
industrialized countries with high
levels of vaccination
are on the verge of being overwhelmed
hey so that rationale is out the window
that is not a reason for us not to go
back to work it's not really even a
reason for us to ask at this point
especially if we're vaccinated if you're
unvaccinated and you want to prevent
yourself from getting it
and you don't want to spread it to
somebody else unvaccinated well then by
all means go ahead and mask but
if you are vaccinated the idea that you
should be masking in public places is
really really dumb
okay beyond that the the notion that we
have seen here
which is that we are we are now
experiencing
the the next goal post that was set up
if you recall there's the goal post of
don't overwhelm the hospitals then
there's the goal post of
wait and shut everything down and mask
up and be very careful until every adult
has had the chance to get the vaccine
welcome to now every adult in the united
states above the age of 12
has had the chance to get the vaccine
everyone and if you choose not to get it
no one can bully you into it and frankly
the attempts by public policy makers to
call you an idiot
enough times that you go and get the
vaccine does not seem particularly
successful by pole data all it's doing
is alienating people it's not driving
them
if people actually felt driven the
reason they would feel driven is not
because anthony fauci was lecturing them
or joe biden was lecturing them
or because some actress from hollywood
was out there telling young people to
get vaccines
the reason that people would go get
vaccinated right now is if they felt
under serious threat the same way that
older people got vaccinated on mass
because they felt
under serious threat and yet our public
policy
makers they don't have an end goal now
right there is no end point to this
they are now using arguments that
basically argue they can they can limit
your liberty
and force you to mask up under under any
and all circumstances
right there is no limiting principle to
anything they're saying right now
because again we surpassed that first
goal post which was don't overwhelm the
hospitals then we surpassed the much
more important second
goal which was make sure everybody has
an opportunity to vaccinate and now it's
just this kind of
measmatic well you know we might have to
mask up forever because you know there
could be
another variant okay well if there's
another variant
then we'll talk about it but this notion
that we're all going to mask up right
now
for the rest of time because this is
true forever right there could be
another variance of this virus in five
years
in fact there could be a completely
different virus in five years why not
mask prophylactically for the rest of
your life and mask your children at the
same time
there's no limiting principle to that
the same thing is true with regard to
some of the lockdown policies that are
now being discussed we're supposed to
lock down travel we're supposed to
prevent people from traveling across
borders
what's the limiting principle here is
there any
as mentioned in the united states people
are now dying at a rate that is similar
to the rates that people die on a daily
basis from like alzheimer's disease
is that a rationale for locking down
large cities in the united states
and that's exactly what we're saying we
are seeing the left the public policy
folks who run our health systems are
obsessed with power this is a power grab
again when this was rooted in ignorance
that was one thing when you were saying
shut it all down because we don't know
what this virus is going to do that was
one thing
it became clear that the lockdowns were
ineffective generally ineffective by the
middle of the summer
last time last year and now we're still
doing the same routine based on a threat
that is not even remotely close to
what we were experiencing back in
january thanks to the presence of the
vaccines
thank god how disconnected is public
policy
from reality at this point it's the
american academy of pediatrics
put out a recommendation yesterday that
is utterly crazy
their recommendation is that we have to
start masking all the children
it is deeply important that we mask all
of the kids pretty much for the rest of
time
according to nbc new york everyone older
than age two
should wear masks regardless of
vaccination status when schools reopen
in the fall
according to updated guidance from the
american academy of pediatrics released
on monday
the leading national pediatrician group
said it recommends universal masking
because so much of the student
population isn't yet eligible for
vaccination
it's not clear how quickly that will
change or how likely parents will be to
get their younger children dosed when
the federal government approves shots
for kids
under the age of 12. and seriously i'm
not sure about dosing my kids
i have kids who are seven five and one
there are no longitudinal studies on the
effect on children
not only that the threat to kids from
covid is not severe
if we were talking about something like
polio and if we were talking
about something like even measles mumps
rubella that would be one thing we are
talking
about a disease in covet 19 that has
killed from 2020 through 2021
a grand total in the entire united
states where there are 75
million people under the age of 18.
there's remember 75
million kids are in the united states
below the age of 18.
the number of kids who have died under
the age of 18 from covet 19
as of yesterday was 335
out of 75 million by contrast the number
of kids who had died
last year and this year from pneumonia
was 809
the notion that that i'm going to start
experimenting on my kids
with non-logic and longitudinally proven
vaccinations when the risk to my
children from covet is extremely low
is it arguable at best right i mean
that's a very arguable assessment so the
idea now is that we're going to force
you
to mask your kid up based on what based
on what if the idea is you have to
protect the teachers
well i have a way to protect the
teachers in fact i have two ways to
protect the teachers
one is that we could have the teachers
wear masks if they are really upset
about it right get every teacher in n95
because n95s protect you
and the idea of cloth masks is they're
supposed to protect everyone else from
when you sneeze but an n95 is also
supposed to protect you or
have an even better solution the
teachers need to facts if the teachers
are really worried about being infected
by children then they should go get the
vaccinations because it turns out the
vaccinations are incredibly good
they're terrific at what they do instead
you have the american academy of
pediatrics
saying i'm supposed to ask my
two-year-old or my three-year-old
based on what the risk that they're
gonna
get hit by lightning right a risk lower
than pneumonia
are you kidding me i mean this is b it's
just bad public policy and it's being
pushed
by all these people why because if you
are in the public health
situation right if you're a public
health expert your sole goal
is to quote unquote kill cover but
that's not a real goal right
it's never going to go to zero covert is
likely to turn into something seasonal
like a weak strain of the flu maybe like
a cold eventually we can hope
if i covet is unlikely to go away it's
just too widespread
it's not going to go away there are
millions and millions and millions of
people
who have already had it who might get it
again we've been saying this since the
beginning is that it's likely to be
seasonal
so this this belief that you can wipe it
out that zero covet is the goal that
means that we're locked down forever
realistically speaking it means that no
one is ever
going out again without a mask and yet
you have all of these
ridiculous foolish
public health leaders trying to suggest
that this is rational public policy it's
not even close to rational public policy
here for example is nih director francis
collins saying that masking children
is a great idea they will not be popular
amongst parents and kids who are sick of
masks but you know what the virus
doesn't care that we're sick of mass
the virus is having another version of
its
wonderful party for itself and to the
degree that we can squash that by doing
something that maybe is a little
uncomfortable
a little inconvenient it's not like
we're asking people to go to the
trenches with uh shooting war we're just
asking you
if it looks like it's gonna help put the
mass back on for a while
okay we're talking about children i also
don't send my kids to trenches in a
shooting lore
like what are you talking about this
is unbelievable they can't explain why
the vaccinated should wear masks
because really there's there's not a
good rationale they can't explain
certainly why children should be wearing
masks but they want you to do it anyway
because after all it's all we're asking
of you the sacrifice is the point
the control is the point if dr anthony
fought you the greatest of all doctors
outside of joe biden saying the exact
same thing
in every respect the cdc always leaves
open
the flexibility at the part of local
agencies local enterprises local cities
and states
to make a judgment call based on the
situation on the ground
so i think that the american academy of
pediatrics you know they're a thoughtful
group
they analyze the situation and if they
feel that that's the way to go i think
that's
reasonable thing to do it is not a
reasonable thing to do
the fact that it's pre that we're
pretending it is reasonable to mask up
three year olds is insane
it's it's totally crazy and by the way
if you're worried your three year old's
gonna get it get your kid
in at 95. now you're gonna save yourself
wait a second my three-year-old isn't
capable of properly wearing an n95
right your your three-year-old isn't
capable of properly wearing a mask
period
right that's the whole point it's such
foolishness
l.a county by the way here's like
let me show you how bad the reporting is
on this stuff and it's from yahoo news
la county is now recording more than 10
000 coronavirus cases a week
a pace not seen since march an alarming
sign of the dangers the delta variant
poses to people who have not been
vaccinated and heightening pressure on
health officials to reverse the trend
so what does this mean okay so l.a
county
um how many deaths are they having okay
because
i know that you're talking about cases
now right cases are wow new cases
my goodness they're seeing like 10 000
cases that are diagnosed every day
okay here are the number of deaths in
l.a county okay
average seven day average rolling
average per day
six six
the population of la county is like
10 million people so six people are
dying today
in l.a county of coved and you're
talking about forcing everybody to mask
in indoor places and masking up all the
kids
you're talking about this as though this
is a massive crisis because l.a county
is seeing 10 000 coronaviru cases a week
not a day a week
a week okay again let me remind you that
the number of coveted cases that were
being seen
in la county as of like january
they were seeing like 20 000 cases a day
not a week this is all crazy
new york city is doing the same stuff
new york city councilman mark levine who
chairs the health committee
is calling for the indoor mask mandate
to be reinstated in the city
even for the vaccinated so what exactly
are the covet
statistics for new york city right now
the coveted cases the the number of new
coveted cases a day in new york city is
like
700 cases in the entire city of new york
the number of deaths in new york this is
actually the entire state
the entire state is averaging six deaths
six this is madness and yet it's being
treated as though it's a crisis
and so the question becomes why are we
treating this as a crisis why is it
important
and the answer as we'll see is control
it's all about the control
because if you can treat everything as a
crisis this allows you to control
everything all the time and this goes to
the
broader the broader agenda that you see
from the democratic party and the media
all the time
all right so if you look at how the
media and the democratic party
see the world crisis is always required
in order to effectuate change this is
why joe biden came into office and he
said we have four crises that are on the
table
climate change and racial polarization
and income inequality
and covid okay none of those things
at the time you might have said covered
was a crisis we were rolling out the
vaccines already so it was a crisis that
was on the lane
the other three are not crises okay
climate change is an issue that is
worthy of consideration with regard to
adaptive measures that governments can
help take in order to protect for
example
low-lying populations can you build more
sea walls sure
can you make sure that infrastructure is
updated absolutely
can you put some money into rnd sure but
it is not
a crisis climate change is not a crisis
the gradual warming of the globe over
the course of the next century
is not a crisis nor by the way are there
any solutions to that crisis
in destroying the entire economy of the
globe that's not a solution all the
stuff that's already in the air is going
to stay up there for another 10 000
years
so the idea that that covid is a cro
that
climate change the crisis is not right
but as you see the left says climate
change is a crisis
therefore we need best redistribution of
wealth
green new deal we need to we need to
take capitalism and destroy it
in order to save the planet because
crisis then you have the crisis
of racial polarization of the racial
reckoning
a crisis that demands wait for it equity
policy
from the white house that looks toward
equality of outcome between the races
and involves the subjugation of
capitalism and merit
in favor of equality of outcome
regardless of the activities
undertaken right we need a
transformation of how america works
based on the
crisis of racial reckoning you know you
may have noticed there was no crisis
there was not as of 2008 racial
relations were the best point they'd
been
in the history of the united states and
then barack obama and the democratic
party decided to play racial politics
specifically in order to
voice him to re-election despite his
unpopularity
then there was the crisis of income
inequality and this one is perfectly
obvious income inequality is not crisis
it depends on poverty could be a crisis
theoretically poverty could also just be
an endemic condition of human life but
poverty could theoretically be a crisis
but income inequality itself is not a
crisis just because jeff bezos is rich
that's not a crisis but this crisis of
income inequality was going to drive joe
biden to spend
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars that had not yet been minted
we're just going to produce this money
out of thin air crisis is an opportunity
and this has always been the case with
big government advocates
crisis is always the way that you
maximize your own power
and so if you declare covet a continuing
crisis this allows you
to maximize your own power now the way
that the biden administration and the
media are seeking to maximize their
power is by essentially saying that
because covet is a crisis
we should take the reins on
informational dissemination we talked
about this yesterday
it continues today and it's going to
continue for the uh for the estimable
future
the democratic party and the media have
an agenda
their agenda is to control the means of
distribution of information
they don't want you to see information
they don't want you to see and covet is
a perfect opportunity for them to
declare anything they don't like
misinformation
and then to quash it so the game here is
to pretend
that vaccine hesitancy is solely the
repository of the right
now here's the problem vaccine hesitancy
is not solely the repository of the
right
as it turns out ac biracial data
hispanics and blacks are the two racial
groups in the united states who are
least likely to get the vaccines
those are also the two racial groups in
america that were least likely to have
voted republican
in the last election cycle okay so that
is not
a convincing case that the only people
in the united states who are not getting
the vaccine are not getting it because
of right-wing propaganda
it's also true that a huge number of
people who aren't getting the vaccine or
who are
vaccines skeptical or maybe already had
coveted and don't want the vaccine and
maybe a lot of those people live in
rural areas because
one thing that we saw with regard to
masking actually throughout the pandemic
is that people
undertook as you would expect rational
risk assessment when pandemic numbers
went up in people's areas they started
to mask
when the pandemic numbers went down
people started to unmask
because that again is how people act
when they are confronted with an actual
risk
but the media have an agenda and the
agenda is to suggest that if it were
only if we could only
stop people like trump from talking stop
people
on fox from talking if we could just
stop all of this
if we could end quote-unquote covered
misinformation well then everybody would
get vaxxed
because human beings don't have agency
obviously
all we have to do is give them the right
information from msnbc and cnn and then
they will they will get facts now
this of course ignores a bunch of holes
in this theory
hole number one as i've mentioned huge
percentages of population that are not
republican are not getting vast
hole number two in this particular
theory
is the fact that there are a lot of
people who are not getting vast
not because of watching fox news or
because of donald trump but because
they do not trust the authorities and
the reason they don't trust the
authorities is because the authorities
have taken every single position on
coveted as possible to take from the
beginning of this pandemic
dr fauci the great and sainted was
saying don't mask up and then he was
saying oh yeah i lied you should mask up
dr fauci the great and saint was saying
don't open the schools then you say oh
well you can open the schools dr fauci
the great and sainted
was saying that once you get the vaccine
you still need to wear a mask and then
he was saying well you really don't need
to wear a mask anymore and now he's
saying well maybe you do need to wear a
mask
maybe there's a great lack of trust in
our scientific institutions because they
spent all of last summer
saying that if you're protesting
lockdowns then you are going to spread
covet and kill everyone but if you are
out there in the streets working for
george floyd then probably you'd be fine
in other words maybe you lost your
systemic trust because you don't deserve
the systemic trust of the american
people
now again that's not a case against the
vaccine i'm not sure there's anybody on
the right who's pro-vaccine azaya
i've been encouraging people to get the
vaccine since literally the first day it
was available
i couldn't have been more excited to get
the vaccine i got it my wife got it my
parents got it i was pumped about it
i think the vaccine is a medical miracle
i also understand why people don't trust
the people who have been saying this
sort of stuff
but again agenda is the only thing that
matters here so
manufacture a new coveted crisis again
we are not in a position of covered
crisis in the united states the stats do
not bear this out
if there is any sort of crisis in terms
of people who are dying it is
a crisis among people who decided not to
get vaccinated and then are more likely
to die
and they're adults and they get to make
those decisions themselves and as long
as they're not overwhelming the hospital
system
then we really don't have a public
policy answer to that
but the public policy answer for
democrats of course is shut down
anyone who says stuff we don't like so
here's mika brzezinski
tearing into trump and his media allies
for vaccine hesitancy this of course is
the predicate to the notion
that places like fox news should be
de-platformed
whether you're talking about david
koresh in waco
or the jonestown mass suicides
or donald trump's lies about kovid
people died and people are dying
and they are dying because donald trump
and his
evil allies on cable news and on social
media and on capitol hill
seems like a very strong word evil until
you understand just how many people
this cult continues to kill
okay uh i have just a question you know
by the way that if donald trump had won
reelection
there would be democrats who were
engaging in tremendous vaccine residency
you know that's the case correct
right i mean kamala harris and joe biden
were saying they don't trust the process
by which trump developed the vaccine
and then when they entered the white
house then all of a sudden it was
the process is great everything's
fantastic we fixed it
msnbc's dr bedelia says the same thing
it's social media and right-wing tv that
are preventing vaccinations
again there is this is just not the case
people are independent actors in the
united states they have the ability to
make their own decisions
typically it is younger people who are
not getting the vaccines more rural
people who are not getting the vaccines
because they live in more rural areas
low-income black and hispanic people are
not getting the vaccines at rates that
really
are where they should be the kind of
one-size-fits-all single factor analysis
tucker carlson says x
therefore people aren't getting the
vaccine ignores the fact that even if
you look at tucker's audience
hey tucker might have four million
people a night watching him
a huge percentage of those people by the
way are older and probably vast
but beyond that the the bizarre notion
that widespread vaccine hesitancy is
solely due to tucker carlson
or social media as opposed to all of the
other factors mentioned
including some somewhat rational vaccine
hesitancy
i'm not saying that i agree with people
who are not getting the vaccine
but to pretend that these people are all
dullards who don't understand anything
about how
i mean a lot of the people who are not
getting a vaccine are like i already had
covered it wasn't that bad
a lot of people are not getting the
vaccine or like i live in a rural area i
don't have a lot of contact with people
so do i really need the vaccine is that
like super duper irrational and crazy
i'm not sure it's super duper rational i
might make a different risk assessment
but i also have respect
for other human beings and their ability
to assess risk
but because the left believes that
everyone can be controlled from above
their conclusion is that if people make
a decision different than their decision
it's because they are controlled from
above therefore if we just stop those
people from controlling people
then we will get our preferred outcome
here is a doctor on msnbc making this
case
what i liked about that that was
released in surgery general is that it's
really pointing to the fact that
this is everywhere right it is the
social media amplification in cases
where
uh and it is it is you know sometimes it
is uh influencers that are on cable
television
right leaning cable televisions but it's
also anytime any one of us
retweets something that without checking
the source we are adding to that
misinformation is out there and i think
it's a whole it truly is a whole society
approach
okay meanwhile joe biden you'll recall
over the weekend he suggested that
facebook was killing people which was
the
which was the predicate for a
governmental intervention in social
media to shut down dissemination of
information
yesterday he quasi reversed himself he
didn't really he said facebook isn't
killing people it's people on facebook
who are saying bad stuff or killing
people on facebook letting them
which means by the transit of property
facebook is killing people here's joe
biden doing it
i had just read that on the facebook
facebook pointed out that it was pointed
out that facebook
of all the misinformation 60 of the
misinformation
came from 12 individuals that's what the
article said so i was asked that
question about
what do i think is happening facebook
isn't killing people these
12 people are out there giving
misinformation
anyone listening to it is getting hurt
by it it's killing people
it's bad information okay and facebook
allowing that
is killing people right so facebook
isn't killing people but facebook is
killing people
in fact says joe biden facebook
shouldn't take it personally when i say
they're killing people they should just
do a better job of shutting down all the
information i don't like
which may change on a day-by-day basis
but since we run all the determination
of information from the white house
via our media allies we should club
social medias doing what we want anyway
my hope is that facebook instead of
taking it personally
somehow i'm saying facebook is killing
people that they would do something
about the misinformation they owe
outrageous information misinformation
about the vaccine
that's what i meant don't take it
personally that the president of the
united states is saying that you're a
murderer
instead stopping a murderer says joe
biden you can see the manufactured
crisis here
and again it is a media manufactured
crisis is driving
the sort of change that democrats have
been wanting for a while which is
restrictions on social media
which is crackdowns on people that they
don't particularly like
meanwhile and this is really amazing jen
saki the white house press secretary
so she was asked you know if it would
help stop vaccine hesitancy would you
praise trump more
like really instead of turning this into
a partisan issue why aren't you out
there
getting trump to for example cut a psa
why aren't you out there saying
the trump administration did a wonderful
job with this and there is a bipartisan
agreement that there's a wonderful
vaccine that everybody should get
wouldn't that be better than you know
being out there and yelling at trump and
being out there yelling at people who
won't take vaccines and telling them
that they're fools and morons wouldn't
that be better and john saki's like you
know we don't need to do any of that
it seems to me your end goal isn't to
get more people vaccinated it seems to
me that your end goal is to polarize the
the constituency here
even if the administration doesn't
partner with the former president
would he consider highlighting or
acknowledging in a greater way his role
in creating the vaccines
to assure the rural voters who still
support president trump that are
hesitant to get the vaccine
well i think do you have data to suggest
that that's the issue that's preventing
people from getting vaccinated
we've seen almost every former president
play a role in putting out a psa making
sure people understood in the country
that the vaccine is safe and effective
we don't believe that requires an
embroidered invitation to be a part of
okay but you could just ask trump to do
it would that would that kill you
i mean the answer is yes because it's
all politics that's the answer
in just one second we'll talk about the
impact of all of this on the stock
market which of course has been
dramatic it's not because the stock
market is afraid of the kovatops
throwing
it's because the stock market is afraid
that governments are going to intervene
and quash the economic recovery
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact you
don't want to go to an auto parts store
because who wants to go
to an auto parts store you stand in line
you finally get to the front of the line
they answer all their very specific
questions and then they look in their
inventory and they say you know what we
don't have the part you're looking for
which is super helpful and they order an
online and charge you or you could just
skip all of that and go directly to
rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear the way airlines do
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts rockauto.com it's family
business serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
but rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog's
unique and remarkably easy to navigate
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about xbox
so they know that we sent you again auto
parts stores aren't great even the best
of times why would you want to wait
around right now in a line instead just
go to the internet the internet's the
way you buy everything these days why
not get the auto parts you need from
rockauto.com great american company
right shapiro on there how did you hear
about xbox so they know
that we sent you alrighty yesterday you
may have noticed that npr
ran an insane hit piece on us here at
the daily wire complaining about our
success as a news organization
basically npr was arguing that facebook
should quash our traffic because we're
really bad because
we're conservative the democrats in the
establishment media
they're ticked off that they don't have
centralized control over the flow of
information
and now the establishment media is in
for another hit
from the daily wire newsroom we're
bringing you a new morning podcast that
values your time and the truth
brought to you by daily wire editor in
chief john bickling and co-host georgia
hell
morning wire will wake you up with the
latest developments in politics sports
culture and education all
with a heavy emphasis on the facts it's
available right now
it's your one stop shop for your news
update in the morning subscribe
to morning wire on apple podcast spotify
and everywhere you listen to podcast so
you don't miss a beat and if you like
what you hear
leave a five star review help us keep
delivering the news you need to know
also as i've been discussing the white
house's attempt to censor anything they
deem misinformation
it is uh it is very authoritarian and it
is just part and parcel of the broader
authoritarian movement
of the left to take over all the
institutions and weaponize them against
you my next book the new book
authoritarian moment it's hitting
shelves next tuesday july 27th
is a supremely important book you need
to read it you need to get your friends
to read it because if you wish for the
country to be saved the authoritarian
moment is a must read
there's a lot happening right now i
first saw in the book you'll want to
pick up your copy of the authoritarian
moment right now to get a sense of
what's coming next
and more importantly how we stop it go
to dailywire.com
ben you can order your signed copy today
again dailywire.com
ben to order your signed copy today
and the fact that the white house is now
trying to crack down on social media is
just the latest indicator that the
left's authoritarianism is creeping into
your everyday life but you knew this
already you know that your corporate
overlords are gonna fire you if you
don't post the black square you know
that your sporting team is going to
chastise you
if you don't have the proper politics
you know that you'll have scientists
like dr fauci telling you that you don't
believe the science if you don't believe
every single thing
that he says about everything even if
he's reversing himself from last week
all of this is symptomatic of an
authoritarian mindset that has
taken root on the left and is now being
crammed down upon you i will be
doing a live stream book signing for the
authoritarian moment next
tuesday the 27th pre-order your signed
copy now when you do you'll be asked to
type in a question at checkout then
catch tuesday's live signing see if i
answer your question watch me sign your
book get your copy at dailywire.com
right now you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty meanwhile joe biden continues
to wish away
inflation and a lot of people including
janet yellen who are saying that
inflation is going to maintain for
several more months
at this point now as i've been saying
there are two forces that are that are
at work in the american economy one is
joe biden
blowing dollars into the american
economy artificially lowering
the labor rate because people are
literally staying out of work because
they're being paid to stay home
and artificially inflating the price of
goods because we have a bunch of
bottlenecks
in all the distribution systems and
that's being exacerbated by money
chasing fewer goods which leads to price
inflation
all of this rooted in the notion that
somehow equity is achieved if you just
helicopter cash to people which has
never been the case anywhere in history
okay so joe biden is saying that that's
not raising inflation no no
you're crazy you might be looking at
that inflation rate and saying yourself
wait a second
i mean the prices are up aren't they he
says no no nobody no one is suggesting
unchecked inflation is on the way says
our our girl was president
there's nobody suggesting there's
unchecked inflation on the way
no serious economist that's totally
different i mean look
the stock market is higher than it has
been in all of history even went
down this month even down this month now
i don't look at the stock market as a
means by which to judge the economy like
my
my uh predecessor did but he'd be very
he'd be talking to every day
the last five months about how the stock
market's so high
higher than any time in history still
higher than any time in history
so that's not how i judge whether or not
we have economic growth
oh well you know he's going to judge you
by the stock market weird he wasn't
doing that when trump was president but
but that's always the way that this
works
then joe biden follows up that doozy by
suggesting that the inflation is
temporary and in fact you know how
you're going to solve inflation
we're going to solve inflation by
artificially boosting the growth
okay this is like the dumbest thing
economically speaking
that i've heard recently his theory is
that inflation
is going up so if you blow more money
into the economy that will jog the
spending which will eventually bring the
inflation down
which is a hell of a take that's a
that's a hot take bull move there cotton
our experts believe and the data shows
that most of the price increases we've
seen
are were expected and and expected to be
temporary
reality is you can't flip the global
economic light
back on and not expect this to happen
as demand returns there's going to be
global supply chain challenges
we've seen that semiconductors which are
used in automobiles
that global shortage has slowed vehicle
production
creating a temporary spike in car prices
that's a real challenge my
administration includes everything we
can to address it
but again these disruptions are
temporary
okay you know what would be temporary is
if you didn't artificially boost the
money supply
it would have been temporary there was
going to be a natural economic recovery
go back listen to my podcast
last year i said when this was over
there would be a major economic boom
because the economy was doing great
and then it was put into an artificial
coma and now the artificial coma is
ending
maybe if the left will allow it to end
and people are going to go out and
they're going to spend again
in fact people ended last year with more
net savings than they had the year
before because the government had
already put so much money in their
pocket joe biden's idea is we're going
to keep spending money
up the wazoo and somehow this is going
to check inflation
interesting idea now the reality is that
when you remove this much money from the
private economy and when everybody
understands
that the the regulatory schemes that
biden is pursuing will hurt business
and that taxation is eventually going to
be around the corner
when everybody realizes that the next
move is that the economy starts to
stagnate
is what we call secular stagnation we've
seen it in japan japan
was the country that was going to take
over the world in the 1980s if you go
back and watch die hard
but in like 1989 1990 you go back to and
you walk die hard
what you'll see is that the nakatomi
plaza right the whole metaphor
is supposed to be that japan was a great
threat to the united states they were
going to be taking over all of our
businesses taking over the world
economically speaking
and then they went into fully uh full-on
like a decade of secular stagnation
because they'd inflated their currency
and it turns out that the demand
was not keeping up with anything
remotely approaching
the supply so what you ended up with was
was this sort of very slow rate of
growth
that destroyed the japanese growth and
boom
of the 1980s by the 1990s japan
basically burned out
you could see exactly the same thing
here and joe biden's own administration
is foreseeing this by the way
you wonder why they're trying to
distract with things like all the
republicans are jim crow donald trump
january
the reason they're doing that is because
they all know that within two years
secular stagnation is likely to set in
and we're going to be growing not at
seven percent
in an artificially boosted rebound from
a pandemic from an artificial
coma what's most likely is that in a
couple of years we're going to be
growing at like 1.8
2 in fact if you look at joe biden's own
10-year proposed budget that budget
suggests that in just a couple of years
we're going to spend the rest of the
decade growing at exorbitantly low
levels
very very low levels the reason the
countries grow
at very low levels is because they have
put too many burdens on the actual
entrepreneurs and job creators in their
economy it's because they've made it
difficult to do business in their
economy
joe biden doesn't care about that
because he understands that the way that
politics works
is that the bigger the things you get
done are the less it matters
whether they actually succeed one of the
great
annoyances that i have with regard to
historians is the way that they treat
for example the 1920s which were a boom
time in the united states as some sort
of horrible time for american governance
and the 1930s which was the great
depression as a wonderful time for
american government
why because political history buffs are
people who are interested in action
they're interested in action and if a
president does big
things it doesn't matter that they're a
complete failure lbj very important
president complete failure
fdr very very important president
absolute failure
on virtually every level except for the
handling of world war ii
hey fdr's handling of the great pressure
was egregiously bad
and there's a great hilarity to the fact
that presidential historians rate
herbert hoover super low but fdr super
high when fdr
literally did what herbert hoover did
except a little more
in fact everybody in the fdr
administration acknowledged that they
were doing what herbert hoover did
the reason that herbert hoover is
treated with disdain and fdr with glory
is because fdr of course was a democrat
and herbert hoover was a republican but
the best presidents of the 20th century
at least up until ronald reagan the best
presidents of the 20th century
were the presidents of the early 20s
william harding
calvin coolidge and these are the people
who are disdained how do i know that
they were good presidents
look at the economic growth rates from
1920 to 1929.
massive and if you say well look at the
great depression that was 1920 yes
that's true because the reaction to the
great depression was not
to sit there and wait for it to peter
out instead
the reaction to the stock market crash
of october 1929 was to get government
involved in
extremely invasive ways in american life
and but this again goes to why joe biden
is doing any of this
because if you're joe biden the
incentives for politicians and this is
true for members of congress it's true
for senators it's true for president
the incentives the incentive structure
is to get big things done
and this is the problem with
centralizing this much power in the
hands of government
whether you're talking about the public
health establishment or the incentive is
to control
centralize and quote unquote get things
done or whether you're talking about in
the financial sphere
where the incentive is to control and
centralize and quote unquote get things
done
the first rule of politics and public
health should be very simple
do no harm but that's not the political
incentive
the political incentive is do something
you see this all the time when people
talk politics they say yeah i see a
problem why can't we just
do something just do something we should
be treating politics like a doctor would
treat a patient
the first rule is don't kill the patient
do no harm
and yet that is precisely the opposite
of our of our modern incentive structure
particularly the media where people who
are the most activist
are considered the most thoughtful and
the and the greatest leaders
why andrew cuomo was a hero while
killing all the olds in his state
while ron desantis who basically
restricted his action to protecting the
elderly
was considered some sort of horrific
human rights violator by the left
we need to change our mindset with
regard to what government is designed to
do otherwise we are just going to get
endless government quote unquote action
that brings about precisely the opposite
of that which it intends to to
bring about all right we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content coming up soon
the matt wall show airs at 1 30 pm
eastern be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the men shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo widdowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show